[Music]
i'm ancient mobius by the way
are you taking me somewhere to kill me
no that's where you just were
i'm taking you someplace to talk but i
don't like to talk
but you do like to lie which you just
did because we both know you
love to talk
how long have you been here i don't know
it's hard to say you know time passes
differently here in the tba
what does that mean you'll catch up
so you're part of the tva's courageous
and dedicated workforce
yes you were created by the timekeepers
yep
to protect the sacred timeline correct
is that funny the idea that your little
club decides the fate of trillions of
people across all of existence at the
behest of three
space lizards yes it's funny it's absurd
i thought you didn't like to talk
i know what this place is
the timekeepers have built quite the
circus
and i see the clowns are playing their
parts to perfection
big metaphor guy i love it makes you
sound super smart
i am smart i know okay okay
please sign to verify this is everything
you've ever said this is absurd
sign this too
[Music]
we protect the proper flow of time
you picked up the tesseract breaking
reality
i want you to help us fix it
why me i need your unique low-key
perspective
do i get a weapon yeah
you really believe in this loki variant
luckily he believes in himself enough
for the both of us
bye it is adorable
that you think you could possibly
manipulate me
i'm 10 steps ahead of you
you're not big on trust are you
you can't trust me okay i've studied
almost every moment of your entire life
you've literally stabbed people on the
back like 50 times
why never do it again
[Music]
you